Aaron so many times scientists have
wondered is it somehow possible that we
can set up an interplanetary
communication system so we don't have to
wait hours to days for messages to go
back and forth within the solar system
for example if you want to communicate
with the Mars rover sometimes it takes
up to 20 minutes 20 minutes for a signal
to go from Earth to Mars and then
another 20 minutes for a message to come
back you certainly cannot carry on a
conversation between two people this way
so some people have said what about
gravity or what about another way to
send messages around the solar system
well there's a problem there
first of all Newton said the gravity
moves instantly throughout the solar
system if the Sun for example were to
disappear right now right now the Sun
were to disappear Newton would say that
instantly throughout the universe
everybody knows that our Sun has
disappeared but along comes Einstein who
says not so fast not so fast if the Sun
were to disappear the shock wave of
gravity travels at the speed of light so
it would take eight minutes eight
minutes for us to be aware of the fact
that our son has disappeared so gravity
waves also travel at the speed of light
not to be fair no one has ever measured
this I repeat no one has ever measured
the speed of gravity however most
scientists do believe that gravity
travels at the speed of light so in
other words to answer your question we
simply don't know of a communication
system that would allow us to link up
all the planets of the solar system
instantly light can't do it gravity
can't do it we're faced to the fact that
Einstein is the cop on the block